[Musique]
l'artiste n'a pas décidé où il va il est
et on lui demande d'aller donc c'est mon
travail c'est notre travail mais là je
vais vous dire un truc c'est que c'était
différent cette fois je savais qu'il y
avait une négociation pour que je vienne
avec les agents etc et puis les
négociations étaient en train de tomber
à l'eau et donc j'étais sur le point de
pas venir ce qui me rendait très triste
parce que ça faisait au moins une
dizaine d'années que j'avais envie de
venir au sac qu'il faut et donc j'ai
appelé les organisateurs je dis il faut
quoi pour que je vienne et donc on a
rangé les choses comme ça et je suis
venu
[Musique]
sauf que chaque festival a une
philosophie défend quelque chose des
fois ou des couleurs ou des fois une
ouais une philosophie une des valeurs
etc et ça faisait très longtemps que je
me disais mais le cercle qu'il faut ça
correspond vraiment à ma manière de voir
le monde à ma manière de voir ce que
c'est l'identité culturelle comment
défendre une musique comment défendre
les musiques comme étant une seule et
même culture et je suis très content que
ça soit chéri
si je dois prendre j'ai pas de j'ai
aucun lancement j'ai zéro j'ai que des
feuilles blanches
c'est un album qui s'appelle capacity to
Love qui est mon 17e album mon 15e album
studio et il est c'est un peu la
continuité de tout le travail que j'ai
fait avant mais avec une avec quelque
chose peut-être d'un peu plus ancré dans
le dans le sol dans dans aujourd'hui
dans ce qu'est la culture d'aujourd'hui
la culture urbaine la culture du monde
d'aujourd'hui la culture
il y a beaucoup il y a pas mal de titres
qui qui s'apparentent à ce qu'on
considère comme étant la culture hip-hop
même si je viens pas du hip-hop mais que
j'adore ça et que j'ai travaillé avec
des producteurs qui vraiment m'ont amené
vers ça et puis d'autres choses aussi
mais voilà c'est un projet qui est
vraiment très très coloré on est là je
pense pour faire la fête pour danser
pour chanter etc donc c'est une autre
c'est une autre manière de faire des
concerts et
voilà je m'attends plutôt on va dire à
ça
[Musique]